[Musik]
da steht mona vetsch mit dem google
reader handorgel honig plan
griechisches
[Musik]
das war bevor irgendeine gemeint wäre
alles inszeniert
die strahlen sie und bali und
spitzbergen dies wird die austria hat
man mir
los geht's der transit oft monat offen
handy nach hamburg
monika vana
ja
so schlägt fehl
[Musik]
jetzt suche hörnli alles im schnitt
bis zum gott truck dass die tiere den
ganzen
monat aus martinique grenze
richtig heimelig lokal menschen die sich
selbstlos und machen
friedrichsdorf
[Applaus]
ich
hoffe nützt mut für die nächsten tag ist
mona vetsch auf dem größten friedhof vor
der schweiz auf gut vorbereitet aber auf
alles gefasst das ist srf heimatland
monat mit drin
wobei wir einmal tätig und wechselte
friedhof
mit dem land da wie nie
[Musik]
wenn ich sage ja gerade er war
mit dem ki.ka klinischer leiter vor der
linie gezogen
das ist super herrlich erhole mich jetzt
gar so kurz
vorm ersten
der schreibschrift ich brauche wirklich
unterstützt also ist wenig traurig auf
dem petersplatz mit dem größten fehler
schweiz auf
den markt
er glaubte die zone herum
der friedhof am hörnli ist so groß wie
fünf fußballfelder
verglich die strom mit dem elektroauto
unterwegs mit dem papamobil wären
wenn das so groß ist
ja zum nein findet glück ist ganz toll
und zum teil stimmt seine
weltklasse
hat sich alles kapiert
lassen alles ein
bisschen krach
traditioneller art entspricht einem
bedürfnis und auch um den neuen ablehnt
hr1 ist sowie spiel hatte schraubt sich
unter mir gemeinschaftsbank das findet
dort statt
und 3
gewesen sind dann sollte dieses jahr
wolle diese kräfte mobilisiert durch
seite marc lüthi
damit drohte die lage irgendwie wochen
noch lange nicht gebannt und habe bis
jetzt nur noch abschätzig als grüßen
alle viele
wild wings wieder oben und wenn man ja
in der lage weiß nicht gut haben nie
gestellt und felix muster
der ernstfall und wie drei minister
felix mussten
wirklichkeit ist das die niedrigste das
runter familie mit dabei ja du hast das
zeug ja
ich sind so
frage mich nur ich würde sagen
ein anderer chef nicht
ernsthaft nach gleichheit und takko witz
machen mit ernstfall und felix muster
als
schwarze humor bruch zwischen friedhof
und bastler sind wirklich speziell
sowie spielt eine interpellation holt
man nicht wählen fc grad machen dann
haben sie dafür haben was ist graf der
fc barcelona das in die erste
installation vor wäre sicher politisch
und und und
mai nicht wo wir vom regierungsrat jetzt
tätig wenn ihr bedürfnis dass sie
betroffen aber es muss bedürfnis muss
vor der fcb sieht artikuliert
bis jetzt ist es also jeder denkt aber
ich spüre schon gar nicht langsam wieder
[Musik]
ok ich sagen denn die
verstaubte zur not würde der gärtner
solange dies war wirklich eine setzliste
[Musik]
bombay ist ein vater ist stark sie sind
erste liga der benji mit 16 jahren kommt
für ihn ist das alles ganz natürlich
mir hilft das aber
reiche hoffe das ist so eine
stellenaufbau ringsum mit
mehrere vielzahl als organisator volk
und da können wir dann verstorben idole
sondern einleiten und einen sagen so
die idee war dass du uns mitteilt von
trafen auch mitarbeiter
von uns und den
hast du
gut jetzt nicht aber das war nicht so
ich habe jetzt zum glück führt wohl
forschten hier direkt mit dem drucken
von dioxinen und jetzt plötzlich zu
drehen das überfordert magazin
[Musik]
wir wollten daher folgendermaßen
extrem extrem herzklopfen 8-schlappe
freudig lacht ja ich habe mir ein toter
mensch also ich kann es nur besser sein
sollte eine fernsehserie und vom bestand
die sind alle in etwa genau so und das
ist jetzt echt ich glaube dass hinterher
und wenn ich sage
die stanzen publiziert und wer heute auf
[Musik]
gern hätten
wir auch die luft danach hört die kleine
tier von cott erfolg und ein echter
kommt sie wagen mit dem verstorbenen
frau
es ist ein toller moment
geleistet wenn du sie wenn du sie jetzt
das toxisch was sie für das leid und das
sich
vereinigen jährlich kann
ja aber ich glaube dass das muss dass
das dass roche zusammen sehr
pragmatisierten und sage für mich seit
der verwendete job wenn ihr schon noch
was ihr holz bearbeitet werden minute
was ihn im jura moore wo war ich mache
von minijobbern bürger auf dass der job
muss auf dann gut und und super lediger
und er wird liegt die hinterbliebenen
die damen sind jetzt friede stellungen
und die räume und respekt an verstorbene
gegenüber auch wenn ich mir jetzt beten
verstorbene mit frage und ich glaube
nicht dass sie denn der job machen aber
man im depot saks todesfall im dorf da
ja damals das
natürlich so viel also doch entsetzt
brake vor dir wird das sah man ja schon
gemacht
es ist schon ein name fehlt weil man
hätte die person kennt und aber für mich
ist wichtig sich als auch unbedingt weil
er mache weil ich bin ich in ihre
politiker das war irgendwie wenn die
potenzen der macht irgend ein bisschen
und mischt das hat dann ja jetzt
irgendwie zum eine fremde gut so das war
heiss familie hat für wenige stunden
also das kann sie den letzten
freundschaftsdienst
jetzt hast du wohnst davids helfer in
der mark schon beste und schuf hier
muss die strecke ja mit den wichtigsten
hause
ich habe man immer schwierig für uns
beliebten talkshow haben die landebahn
hinaus und auch inhaltlich stehe also
was merz finde das gut
besetzt ist
standing
es ist eine erstaunliche dem moment
sobald man sich seht ist es nicht so
schlimm
wie man denkt
und denkt schon mensch
und uns inspiriert dass alle wege zumal
ihre später ausfliegen
[Musik]
jetzt wo nie der erste tote mensch vom
in leiberg sehen bin ich doch
tatsächlich errichtet
eigenartige
[Musik]
studiere schon über leid tut dem wetter
in ri
dies macht noch einmal dass sich mini
misst gestreut wird
also sichert hälfte
und wenn jetzt viele fragen meint
ziemlich dem audi avant historische
machen dann können sie es mehr als der
hälfte diamant machen oder wenn es
möchte schon in einer wohnung leben
etwas der heimat wenn sie das wilde hat
sie das aber sonst rasch tasche
ich werde desto niedriger
der muss mich weiter lügen und -muster
zahlen dass man pflegen und der
wirtschaft anstrebt
wir bringen sagt sally frick vom
friedhof alle start passen das anrecht
auf dem friedhof am öffentlich kostenlos
begraben zweiter basel stadt sagt
inklusive
das sind nur gedrückt
[Musik]
gerade die sowie vom friedhof als re
strand mit des bads im roggen in dhaka
tierisch macht
das wenn das in ordnung ist mit sich
durch den friedhof
[Musik]
es ist spezielle stimmig und ihre morgen
früh über die friedhof spazieren
der ort gibt ein ruhe aber ich muss auch
im moderat denke dass jeder von einem
grabstein führen mensch und sinnig
gstaad
mit dem ein anderer besuch auf dem
friedhof
sie hat eine krebs multiple myelom und
wirklich eine für die aggressive
damit sie
jeden tag zwei mal sicher
das ist der witz will ich ja das sagen
sie mir felix
loß nicht ich weiß was ich muss machen
und dann entscheiden was die anderen
sagen
soll ich sagen wir mal 48 jahre zusammen
mir es ist schwer auf einmal denn ich
glaube immer habe ich dennoch nicht das
sind immer da ich aber
der ort finde ich also wirklich morgen
beschreibt das ist mir ein paar kein
friedhof
obwohl sie formal grabstein steht ja ja
klar
das sind einfach nicht was mir seid doch
hinter leader nach
und beide demo lustig macht sie nicht
die rede und muss ersetzt einzig mit der
erfahrung haben gab gestern zwei neue
kids und sie sehen ist
antwortet was sie machen glauben sie
denn ganz offen manchmal ist alles ja
und wenn sie rose das essen sie denn
wenn rote rosenblätter es im blick
nummer dastehen und
dass nicht das sind jetzt schon ein buch
aus dem 100
vielleicht
[Gelächter]
suchen
der friedhof das merkt jetzt ist kein
ort für die tote zwischen ort für die eu
und für ihre jährige
[Musik]
das größte friedhof aus kaum zu
subjektiv sind dass ich viel haut
gärtner macht hält die fahne nach stellt
auf dem friedhof am howard hughes
mit ökostrom schmiede
hinzu kommt
dass mit beruhige heißt er ja da bin ich
einfach das wohl abgefahren ist im
schnitt schutzprogramm zone
[Musik]
lang ist auch friedhofsgärtner und
sichere jobs
traditionell
[Musik]
macht fischer art wird den sie dann
immer spritze zu schalten
schweineblut oder horn mal rhythmisch
content über das fg bestückt sind dass
wir haben uns eigentlich gut im griff am
anfang stand ein
großes tief mit wenn wir das erreicht
das saarland vertreten
die ein treiber sind liebevoll pflegt
andrick 7 fast nimmer will die man jetzt
eine überwucherte kripo
dass jemand im ausland age und dann
wieder zurück und und man gut daran das
grab an und plötzlich ist nichts mehr
ohne dass er das darf man die 32 mietet
hat sie also heiß
zu wachsen
du hast mal wenn du so dass gravano ich
mich wahrscheinlich dass sie also
erfindet für mich dass sowohl ricke als
auch bei uns trainer ist einfach so dass
immer die wohnung passen und man kraft
glück denn und irgendwie ist das auch
finde ich langsam zusammenhalt in der
familie
man hat einfach kurz hier hat sich das
gestorben jetzt macht es dann eggstätt
und so ist das lied gegangen und das ist
ein bisschen verloren
[Musik]
die allermeisten tote werden
unter dem platz tore führten lange gang
ins krematorium
[Musik]
und das ist doch lange gang zuletzt war
eigentlich
da schafft wird chambtal müller sie hat
verschiedene aufgaben hätte ich sie für
zur logistik zuständig
mit gut das wird dann in corner gelenkt
ja das ist sich
der sitzung nicht wo es lieblichkeit wo
nach wo es schicksal machst du das
überlastete und du logement weiß genau
was er muss natürlich alle burgen und
kontrollieren und also sich mir schon
bewusst dass so natürlich menschen
strikt
ab
ich danke darf sich mit so viel gedanken
darum machen weil sonst kommen so
albrecht also viel fantasie den trafen
noch
ya auf der anderen seite weil meine
horrorfilm luft kann man sagen
doch stimmt es nicht
anhand der bilder zum beispiel oder ok
also mit
sie hat also dass ich jetzt endlich
glaubt der natürliche reflex mensch ist
das willst du und du sollst dieselbe
stufe komisch oder sie mir an dass ich
denke es ist vielleicht eine
späte tore völlig realistisch und jeder
bei uns muss keiner so schnell plötzlich
go und ich glaube mir
bewusst
der fall
[Musik]
das ist stände haben jetzt schon einen
gepard stellen
jeden tag und sage
ministerium selbst
trainiere ja wir sind zugestand
promotion aber wenn du hatten hier über
keinerlei ausgang ja irgendwann mal
konzert und das stück fleisch ich bin
weg schaffen krematorium oder sich auf
dem friedhof
muss ich halt im abc news gesagt also
die ein delikt frage das halt nicht so
wenn wir
verraten hat das ausspricht enorme ist
mit seiner stimme aber zurückhaltend was
sind imz wenn sie die letzten
arbeitstage dem krematorium komplett vom
tisch foto firo funktionieren nur zwei
richtig viel verstorbenen andrew gowers
lift zürich transportiert werbe zu
milieus
das neue krematorium ist sofort
betriebsbereit und der ganze stolz von
friedhof chef marc lüthi es ist nun mal
versteckt unter der erde
die zukunft kam wie im krimi ehrenhain
macht wie sie das bedürfnis von
angehörigen seite mark klicken um das
thema der bahn endlich kriegen ja passt
wir haben die tendenz von der
gesellschaft das lied immer schwer war
und für das haben wir jetzt eine
spezielle over
and over
doch am also bis zu 400 kilo mensch
gremien also extra ein leistungsfähiger
offen
missachtet
besetzt ist vom kilo habe 170 kilo heben
der vorschlag sehe dann hätten wir das
entweder-oder sondern oft oder
abgestattet machen und jetzt und jetzt
könne man hier
ein friedhof ist eben ein moderner
dienstleistungsbetrieb auch wenn sie
realisiert wünsche die nächste die
menschen in anspruch
[Musik]
früher dienten
minute vor sechs jahren begann zum
krematorium
und die drücken vergesst
heftig
richtig heftig interessant heftig
interessant also ohne mich
das wenn konter morgen immer
geschäftsleitung und ich glaube das was
mir ihre grenzen bringt ist für ihn
alltag
im krematorium laufs meister automatisch
das schafft 80
das programm läuft und nach 60 minuten
beendet ist oder ob es noch längere zeit
das kann sie das am 28
im ältere oder auch ein alter mensch zu
mensch zu mensch hoc mit
jugend die personen muskel das brennt es
auch
selbst nur mehr
ahnung ob mir sagen jetzt
haben wir schon der bcf dafür ja jetzt
nur noch drei wörter die offen sind noch
bei möchte sagt positionierte
kontrollblick
auf dem kopfhörer
und da hocken
august lang druck gesetzt
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
ich habe im kopf gehabt stellte musste
wirklich
für mich ist es vorstellbar dass
gaststars ende
das zählen notwendig was damals werte
sehen geht weißt du ich
würde sagen es ist wie das ist ja bloß
das muss ja irgendwann bist warum sind
wir so verschieden
jeder kopf dank der komplett angestrengt
aber im körper hoch mag ist im original
leben es kann nicht fertig sie das
goldene also es muss jetzt passieren was
passiert ist dahinter völlig sinnlos
sind so sieht das westtor die masse
aufbewahrung ihrer hand dass das genau
dass sie nicht vom leben es gibt noch
keinen du lebst du durch die
fortpflanzen und am schluss
würde ich auch vorne sagte und da sagen
was
ist wenn du willst dich das bei dir und
ihr zieht eine vision er die schnitte
mit unglaublich sondern ein
[Musik]
us bank
das total also möchte ich habe mich da
schon mit der seit vielen das ist alles
automatisch
immer das gefühl haben das ist jetzt ein
niveau von marc rath buckley etwas lacht
das ist also
hinter niederlage
mit religion
ganz oben
am nachmittag begleitet und alpiner
bestätigt familie vor der verstorbene
hat villiger das modell für filme es
gibt ja bestätigt unsere
mannschaftsboote
was ist graf krolock
später damit
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
speziell im moment also auch im metropol
diese dinge nicht aber es ist immer
wieder spezielle leben auf mehr
macht sich drüben
eigentlich nicht mehr macht sehr traurig
wenn ich sehe ich das andere zu tricksen
das macht ein eigentlich mehr also das
macht mir
dass ich
heute
obwohl die rückseite mit der verwiesen
aber ja
gegen einen friedhof ist ein
ort wo ich muss ich so viel bezahlt
eigentlich ist so und so dietrich und
pistor ecstasy sind wird ruhe
und ich habe mir mal
meine gehabt eigentlich ein ort von dort
aus
ja
ja ja
ich denke dass mehr
geld
die drei tage auf dem friedhof anhören
wie nachdenklich gemacht
dankbar dankbar dass es manager john tal
benji und das wenn gibt wo in aller
stille dafür sorgen dass mehr altenberg
in würde
[Musik]